I've been working on submarines for
nearly 30 years I lost my family to this
job but I have to take this
and always to get money in Ag Robinson
needs a man like you when you first walk
some other thing that shot you've a
nurse I think that you were gonna pop
these things really are the proximity
own beats and the smell when you say the
smell of diesel and then again chase
better beat I have you managed to shoot
today just as they do when they are on a
submarine an awful lot of politeness and
patience and you know waiting for people
to pass and shuffle yes everyone into
one corner and then moving into another
corner the biggest scenes that we've
done here are some of the most worthy
and indeed some of the the scenes with
the most people in them equal share
every man
back to your posts well 77 men on board
in its entirety they can go down up to
four months without surfacing when
you're under winter if something goes
wrong you need to bend and screw and fix
pieces to keep the machine going and so
this is a workplace where someone would
have
[Music]
going down and through here if the
engine feel at their backside you've
also got the same on this side there's
actually a drop side so you actually get
into the engine and and this again is
places where people would have slept up
here and sometimes on top of this thing
because it would mean wound but the
sleeping pallets are insane scene pans
are very bizarre cuz there's no you know
you're kind of in charge of keeping
yourself rested but there's no daylight
no but also that everyone is operating
on 24/7 their onyx operational what 20
parts 120 is a little Lewis bug likely
says its usual for reported I said
homies feel uncomfy it's been hard but
because it looks so extraordinary and
like I said I'm sure the the sets which
I've yet to see are apparently brilliant
but but you just kept this such a sense
of history and detail we noticed these
like Morse code dots and dashes give
them in Russian writing next one said as
a firewood and the last one I think his
bad news is the one that's basically
saying too late for us save yourselves
[Music]